oh hey Tracy
hey I just spilled water on my computer
I think it's broken
okay I need you to listen to me listen
to me closely and follow my instructions
exactly you're gonna take this computer
to the stores closet you're gonna leave
it on the third shelf then you're gonna
take this ticket to Kansas
go spend some time with your lovely
mother and lay low for a month until
this all blows over do you understand my
mom doesn't live in Kansas hey guys
thanks for volunteering to help clean
the kitchen guys
Patrick can you do the countertops Tracy
I want you to empty the dishwasher you
don't get to say that if you want me on
me guys I've got some sad news last
night way to let someone go and well Bob
will not be working with us anymore no
he can't go we were supposed to spin in
the Sun together Tracy I'm about this
new guy you've been dating oh my god he
is so funny ha he works out all the time
he's married with three kids
wait he's married he's also the
President of the United States
look look I'm pretty sure he killed my
mom what I love him okay and we're gonna
be together so the great thing about
this is that we should not be met with
what I did science when it comes to
science did you say defiance we told you
about defiance
that sweater fits you really well thank
you fit fits here 752 752 752
should we call someone
hey hey excuse me excuse me he's with me
he's with me no problem scuse me and I
think if we keep our performance up then
we're in for some pretty profitable
games for next year
Bravo Bravo Jesus Jesus Millie not now
not now
it's handled
thank you